an extreme heat wave is sweeping across
western canada
claiming dozens of lives and people
struggle to keep cool
the unprecedented heat smashed canada's
temperature record when the mercury hit
49 degrees celsius
cooling centers have been set up to give
residents some respite from the
sweltering heat which is
expected to last for several days yet
a prolonged dangerous and historic
heatwave engulfing western canada has
already caused dozens of deaths
people are being encouraged to go to
cooling centers to combat the extreme
heat
it's just unbearable it's it's
impossible to be out so
never seen anything like this i hope it
never becomes like this ever again it's
it's not really pleasant this is too
much too much summer for us here
but some are enjoying being outdoors
it doesn't feel like vancouver but it's
an interesting experience
yeah it's been nice getting outside but
basically been consuming gallons of
water
the whole time not surprising with
temperatures exceeding 45 degrees in
some places and feeling close to 50
degrees in others
because of the humid conditions some are
taking to the water to cool down
while others are helping the vulnerable
by distributing food and drink to
provide relief
officials point to this being part of a
wider problem
in this instance i think the the big
lesson coming out
of the past number of days is that the
climate crisis
is not a fiction it is absolutely real
and if you look i've had a briefing from
the
wildfire service uh yesterday and again
today
the entire west coast of north america
from baja to alaska
is red hot this is not a
british columbia problem it's not a
canada problem it is a global
challenge and we all need to have
citizens of the world coming together
school and college classes have been
cancelled in british columbia
which means more play time perhaps but
extreme heat
and the search for relief looks like a
climate emergency problem
that just isn't going away